as a result, we send them our
proposal,
they say war war war it
seems that they may be preparing a
third military operation and warn us in advance
don’t interfere don’t
protect these people interfere you will
protect some new sites
on the trail and it’s being
prepared maybe as the
first option with  brainwashed, which
is why I responded to the
proposal of President Biden who, in a
telephone conversation, proposed to appoint
responsible representatives in order
to negotiate on issues of
strategic stability,
it is clear that one of the most important elements
today is the stability and security of
ensuring security here in this
area in this direction and we  we must
understand how our security will be ensured
, therefore, without any without
these tricks, they simply directly raised the
question that there should not be any further movement of NATO to the
east, the
ball is on their side, they must answer
takes
the
rings online
so the
most  fatty while scales